got this give me that and the winner is
Keith Urban takes home Entertainer of
the Year at Sunday night's ACM Awards
it's been yes and yes that would come in
and love everyone before here never but
you should have come anytime
and so just amazing to be here and part
of this whole community in the love in
that room is astounding there was a lot
of love in the room you are smoking hot
tonight I don't if you know this or not
but smokin hot Miranda Lambert and
husband Brenda McLaughlin made their red
carpet debut ahead of her performance I
got the hail out of Oklahoma
when Stefani cheered on Blake Shelton
from the crowd
we swooned over chrissy mets debut
performance of i'm standing with you
from the movie breakthrough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Chrissie Matt's first time
singing in front of people into my song
called I'm standing with you
and she's gonna be standing with some
pretty heavy hitters up there
[Music]
[Applause]
it's super exciting to be now these
incredible artists to I and fans like
I'm a true fan of all of them and so
it's super cool to like look to your
left and right you're like yeah so it's
really exciting we have to highlight dan
+ Shay winning big with three awards
this is crazy
I'm gonna try not to cry cuz I'm like I
got makeup on I mean I don't know no
it's beautiful yeah we worked so hard
for this and we're just this is the
craziest feeling in the world we were on
the bus after we like we've got
backstage and we we saw her introducing
the next bit and she was like welcome
back to the MGM Grand
or as we like to call it Daniel Shays
wonderful adventure and I think that was
the greatest moment excellent adventures
that was like the craziest thing I was
like that's the coolest that might be
the best thing of the night right there
and Jason Aldean was honored as artist
of the decade still trying to get used
to that one I think you're a little too
young but you're very deserving I agree
that's what I said earlier I don't think
I don't feel like I've been around long
enough to get that you know then I kind
of look back and like well I've been
here a little bit almost 15 years so
maybe it just means you look young for
us to say that I think that's what it is
I think the country music fans country
radio you guys have changed my life
forever
forever
thank y'all so much
[Music]